bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen c'est parti pour 30
minutes d'actualité sur l'europe cette
semaine on s'intéresse au travail
détachées souvenez vous c'était au
milieu des années 2000 l'europe se
déchiraient déjà sur la directive
bolkestein et le plombier polonais
quelques années plus tard force est de
constater que le travail des tâches et
pose toujours problème dans de nombreux
pays et restent souvent synonyme de
dumping social avant d'en discuter avec
mes invités mounir soucy s'est rendu en
belgique pour un état des lieux
reportage alors oui si on est sur les
hauteurs de liège dans le parking de
barks on appelle ça un lieu très
important ou pas mal de camions s'y
installent pour faire leurs coupures et
on peut voir n'est pas d'immatriculation
qui sont là portugais un hollandais les
conditions de vie entre deux camions et
mange
vive la vie un quotidien difficile pour
ces chauffeur bulgare slovaques ou
polonais mais en prenant la route ils
peuvent gagner le double du salaire
moyen dans leur pays pour réduire leurs
coûts des transporteurs belges profitent
de ces écarts de salaire et ouvre
directement des filiales en europe de
l'est
le fait qu'ils soient installés en
tchéquie c'est qu'ils peuvent engager
des gens avec un contrat slovaques
qu'ils soient slovaque uru un peu
importe
n'importe qui et puis il met à
disposition un véhicule qui est souvent
pris ici en belgique et il travaille
au départ de la belgique avec un contrat
slovaque 500 euros brut par mois en
général
cette main d'oeuvre moins chère permet à
ces entreprises de remporter la majorité
des contrats de transport longue
distance laissant au chauffeur belge les
livraisons sur des petits trajets
nationaux frontaliers en belgique
la profession a perdu 6000 postes en une
décennie et sur cette période le métier
a muté au fait cela par la cour
d'assises des petits rayons accrue aux
clients ils prennent le travail tout
simplement bon on peut pas leur en
vouloir
il faut qu'ils vivent aussi mais on peut
pas se permettre de continuer comme ça
l'europe sociale elle est où c'est
d'augmenter les salaires les payes
classe qui soyons un niveau que nous en
attendant cette harmonisation les
sociétés de transport tente de rester
compétitive sur ce marché ouvert
certaines entreprises belges ont cherché
des solutions d'aucune respecte
parfaitement la réglementation d'autres
sont plus en porte-à-faux avec les
règles nous estimons que dès lors qu'on
respecte les règles européennes il n'y a
pas de raison de leur en vouloir
les acteurs qui reste dans les clous
réclame plus de contrôle et de sanction
contre les tricheurs
le gouvernement tente de lutter contre
la fraude il affirme avoir récupéré 200
millions d'euros l'année dernière et
annonce le recrutement de 100
inspecteurs de recouvrement
supplémentaires mais ils misent avant
tout sur une initiative européenne pour
mettre fin aux dérives plan 2014 on a
quand même voter une directive
d'exécution 4 en train d'implémenter
maintenant hein ça veut dire par exemple
qu'on peut travailler ensemble beaucoup
plus facile avec les services
d'inspection des pays tiers donc c'est
un élément clé pour nous deuxièmement
les la proposition de madame test au
niveau européen pour la révision de la
directive et là on donne beaucoup de
soutien à madame test pour clarifier la
définition pour avoir un peu meilleure
collaboration entre différents services
d'inspection et ça veut aussi dire qu'on
est beaucoup plus facile on en voit
beaucoup plus de capacités pour
contrôler les règles ici en belgique
la commissaire européenne mariann 6n à
la mission d'instaurer un alignement des
salaires vers le haut
en accordant aux travailleurs détachés
les acquis sociaux en vigueur dans les
pays d'accueil
une mise à niveau attendu dans le
secteur du transport mais aussi de la
construction en belgique
un tiers des employés du bâtiment sont
détachés les temps sont durs pour les
entreprises qui embauchent exclusivement
de la main d'oeuvre locale dans la
banlieue de liège ce patron a bien du
mal à décrocher des appels d'offres
publics les administrations parce le
marché au moins dix ans moi je me vois
mal exploité dégâts pendant deux mois et
puis leur donner le papier parce que je
vais faire venir un autocar de gauche de
droite c'est pas dans la mentalité c'est
peut-être ridicule de parler comme ça
certaines certains se frottent les mains
en agissant de la sorte mais je ne on
n'est pas encore arrivé à ce point leur
bien qu'on vient de passer deux années
très très difficile un état d'esprit qui
pourrait se révéler payant à quelques
kilomètres dans la ville d'herstal le
maire prépare un chantier donc ici on va
avoir une voirie d'accès qui va venir il
y encore des bâtiments qui doit faire
démolir ce bâtiment la flüela il a mis
en place un dispositif pour soutenir les
entreprises responsables lorsque nous
lançons à marcher à marché ouvert tout
le monde peut répondre mais pour ne pas
être exclu du marché
il faut dans l'offre avoir l'adhésion à
cette charte une charte de bonne
conduite pour envoyer un message est
lancé une dynamique même si la valeur
juridique de ce texte et limiter les
mesures qui devraient prises pour lutter
contre le dumping social ne sont pas
toujours prises ou ne sont pas
pleinement prise et donc au niveau local
on peut avoir un complément d'actions où
on a une maîtrise plus grand sur la
décision l'initiative fait tache d'huile
des grandes villes comme liège namur et
charleroi imiter installe une manière
pour elle de corriger sur le terrain les
lacunes des règles européennes
un peu
alors comment corriger les lacunes
justement de la directive européenne
pour en parler elisabeth morin chartier
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe ppe parti
populaire européen
vous êtes questeur de ce parlement et
vous êtes surtout rapporteur du projet
justement de directives du travail des
tâches et donc pour le parlement
européen donc elle devrait être
présentée en commission d'ici quelques
semaines quoi oui tout à fait bon en
face de vous guillaume balas vous êtes
également député européen membre du
groupe socialiste vous avez rédigé un
rapport il ya quelques semaines vous sur
le dumping social
c'est cela c'est cela mon vous nous en
parlera et enfin nicolas govou suivait
ce dossier depuis toujours vous êtes
journaliste éditeur du blog bruxelles 2
et correspondant de sud ouest bienvenue
à vous alors après ce reportage on voit
que la situation est quelque peu
intenable pour les entrepreneurs on l'a
vu le bâtiment n'a vu le transport vous
diriez qu'il s'agit clairement de
dumping social
qu'est-ce qu'on a ratés dans la mise en
place de ce texte elisabeth morin
chartier pour me rallier à une telle
situation
c'est très clair dans la situation des
travailleurs détachés aujourd'hui en
europe nous reposons sur un texte qui
date de 1996 il ya 20 ans qu'est-ce que
c'était l'europe l'europe c'était 15
états membres avec des écarts de salaire
minimum qui allait de 1 à 3 vingt ans
plus tard l'europe a changé de taille
c'est aujourd'hui 28 états membres et
des écarts de salaires qui vont de 1 à
10 ce qui fait que il y a un jeu qui
s'établit à l'intérieur du marché
européen sur ses salaires concurrence en
un jeu de concurrence un jeu de
concurrence deux salariés et agents de
concurrence d'entreprises un jeu de
concurrence deux salariés parce que il y
à un mouvement évidemment de salariés
qui vont des stones ouest vers les pays
à plus forts salaires et à plus forte
protection sociale s'il ya aussi un
jeune de concurrence entre les
entreprises parce que pour gagner des
appels d'offres
aujourd'hui on voit des entreprises qui
n'hésitent pas à faire appel
des travailleurs détachés pour coiffer
sur le poteau d entre eux et on l'a vu
effectivement l'argent aux pauvres
travailleurs nationaux eu nicolas gros
il n'y a pas eu de tentative depuis 1996
de revoir ce texte mais moi je pense que
là je suis pas d'accord avec madame la
député à l'époque de la directive la
directive a été fait pour le maçon
portugais ce qu'on craignait
c'était que les maçons portugais déborde
sur le marché français au moment de
l'adhésion de l'espagne parce que la
directive
elle est née de sa de cette peur est
maçon cadre il fallait encadrer et
éviter que le secteur du bâtiment
notamment et d'eau de trois autres
secteurs ne soit détruit par une
concurrence déloyale
à l'époque le salaire allait de 1 à 10
entre le portugal et le danemark
donc on avait le même ratio le le
problème c'est que c'est une directive
sellal qui accompagne la lie prestations
de services est pas une directive
sociale c'est une directive qui est
destiné à accompagner en gros une
concurrence loyale entre les entreprises
de part et d'autre elle n'a pas pour but
d'élever le niveau social injuste pour
but d'éviter une concurrence déloyale et
est le deuxième facteur c'est qu'elle ne
concerne que les travailleurs salariés
c'est cela et aujourd'hui on est face à
un marché qui non seulement à une
différenciation de salaire qui restait
stable parce que les salaires ne sont
pas énormément rapprocher la différence
de l'aspect du portugal et de l'espagne
mais on a un atomisation du marché du
travail où la plupart des travailleurs
ne sont plus salariés de l'entreprise
ils viennent en tant qu'indépendant
en gros danger d'une entreprise même pas
intérimaire en sous-traitant de
l'entreprise
donc là théoriquement la directive du
travail détachées ne s'applique pas en
tant que tels dons qui peuvent procurer
une bouille et faire un tarif à 1 euro
de l'heure si vous avez envie c'est
votre problème entre guillemets
d'entrepreneurs individuels
donc là on se trouve face à un nouveau
problème est gérée que c'est un
changement du marché du travail en
europe qui en 20 ans est accomplie donc
il ya tout cet aspect là et la directive
même demain je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle
soit totalement adapté on y reviendra
mais alors guillaume balas le problème
c'est quoi c'est qui
pendant ces vingt ans on a manqué de
contrôle on a laissé les abus
s'installer qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
bois je pense qu'il ya eu
une majorité je dis pas politique mais
une majorité de direction de l'europe
j'ai considéré que ce qui fait d'abord
confiance était le marché unique et la
libre circulation du capital des
marchandises et des des travailleurs et
que en réalité
l'élargissement notamment de l'europe
alès ne s'est pas accompagnée on le sait
bien d'un approfondissement à l'ouest
d'abord pour qu'on puisse proposer des
règles un petit peu claires et donc on
s'est enfermés dans un système où il y a
une économie low cost entre guillemets à
l'est et une économie menacée maintenant
en tout cas pour ces travailleurs à à
l'ouest donc la question avait très
simple c est ce que l'union européenne
est en capacité de compléter maintenant
le marché intérieur par des règles
sociales qui vont vers un processus
d'uniformisation jeudi un processus
parce que ça va pas être du jour au
lendemain évidemment ou est ce qu elle
n'y arrive pas et alors si elles n'y
arrivent pas de manière extrêmement
claire moi je crois qu alors ça sera la
fin de l'union européenne parce que les
peuples le refusons c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont des descendants sur la question du
naming absolument et c'est pour ça
qu'avec son voisin polonais exactement
c'est pour ça que je pense que la
question de cette directive bien sûr ne
réglera pas tout parce que je pense que
c'est il faut attaquer par tous les
bouts la question sociale en europe
évidemment mais elle est quand même
extrêmement importante pourquoi parce
que la question de la clarification
maintenant dans la loi européenne
2 qu'est ce que c'est par exemple la
rémunération d'un travailleur permettra
justement d'amenuiser les jeux entre des
entreprises sur le fait qu'on va payer
moins un tel plutôt que l'autre parce
que l'un et travailleurs détachés et
l'autre est un travailleur le local
donc ce n'est pas un petit débat que
nous avons devant nous et dont elisabeth
morin chartier chargé alors c'est
maintenant un jardin pour rajouter à un
point parce que je suis totalement
d'accord avec eux viennent dire
guillaume balas et je voudrais rajouter
que aujourd'hui même des pays comme la
pologne les pays qui sont situés à l'est
de l'europe commencent eux aussi à avoir
une concurrence déloyale de travailleurs
qui viennent de l'autre côté des
frontières de l'europe qui viennent
d'ukraine et qui viennent à moindre coût
offrir leurs services en travailleurs
détachés dans des pays qui eux son
fournisseur de trains
ailleurs des tâches et ailleurs donc
c'est un vaste mouvement européen sur
lequel il faut que nous apportions de la
régulation du contrôle
les gens attendent plus d'europe sociale
nos concitoyens européens
aujourd'hui si on veut qu'ils croient en
l'europe qu'ils se réapproprient c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut âge et à celles
annoncées sur laquelle on est attendu
qu'il faut à ce que l'agro vous êtes
d'accord
le ver était dans le fruit dès le début
on ne savait très bien on a fermé les
yeux en se disant ça va passer il n'y a
pas de problème c'est comme d'habitude
parce que en 96 effectivement au lecteur
dans une autre époque
je me rappelle très bien d'un débat je
peux même cité le nom de la personne
d'une dg de la dg emploi de la
commission européenne lors d'un débat à
l'université de nanterre paris xii qui à
ce moment là disait il ya un problème
voici lequel est ce problème c'était pas
le problème du travailleur détachées qui
vient avec une entreprise parce que
l'entreprise un chantier sa peau ça pose
des problèmes mais disons que ces
modérés et normalement c'est à peu près
encadré par un par la directive
c'est pas le problème non plus de
l'entreprise multinationale qui détache
un travailleur dans ses différents vous
pousse à poser problème mais ça aussi
c'est maîtriser le problème c'est quand
ça se détache par des triangulaires et
ce problème là mais le double
détachement le double détachement ça
veut dire que c'est une boîte aux
lettres en fait c'est oui si vous
ajoutez nez avec des boîtes d'intérim
vous avez une boîte ya plus aucun
rapport entre le travail le détachement
alors images des ouvriers par exemple
polonais via une entreprise cypriote
vouliez enregistrés en irlande par
exemple c'est ça c'était le cas typique
à l'époque moi je me rappelle très bien
on avait évoqué sa la moitié des gens
rigolaient certains spécialistes savais
que ça pouvait être le problème mais on
pensait à l'époque
même ceux qui étaient les plus
pessimistes se disait ça va rester
juguler et on verra ensuite parce que si
tu as premiers pas cette directive on va
là on voit là bas on sait déjà un
premier pas et comme d'habitude on va là
on va là l'a peaufiné au fil du temps on
l'a pas peaufiner il ya le dialogue sur
l'inspection du travail c'est de la
foutaise
aucun dialogue donc à aucun contrôle n'a
pas mouillé aucun contrôle fesses vous
voulez oui effectivement il ya eu aucun
contrôle du coup alors on n'a pas assez
fait on traite le problème c'est qu'il
ya une asymétrie quand elle me complète
entre les états sur la question du
contrôle ils sont partout insuffisant
mais il y en a où c'est pire qu'ailleurs
et il ya des mesures qui pourraient être
prises parce que là il faut distinguer
deux choses il faut distinguer ce qui
est de l'ordre de l'illégalité qui est
massive et qui pose la question du
contrôle et il faut distinguer ce qui
est de l'ordre des trous dans la
législation aujourd'hui ce à quoi nous
allons nous attaquer là ce sont les
trous dans la législation
il a une directive en 2014 qui a été
posé normalement pour faire en sorte que
ce soit mieux appliquée on peut penser
qu'il ya aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'insuffisances et notamment une sur le
contrôle
c'est pour ça que il va falloir
maintenant monter d'un cran c'était une
des propositions qui a été ratifié par
le parlement que j'avais faite sur le
fait qu'on me mette en place un des
équipes multilatérale au niveau européen
avec plusieurs pays concernés sur la
question du contrôle
c'est la première chose j'ai échoué à
faire passer l'idée d'une inspection
européenne mais je pense que c'est le
bon niveau et la deuxième qui me paraît
absolument aujourd'hui essentielle c'est
d'augmenter le nombre d'inspecteurs du
travail il ya des normes internationales
qui existe l'organisation internationale
du travail a mis d'énormes nous n'y
sommes pas en europe
aujourd'hui il faut les tenir à nice en
panne ont largement pas et enfin un
dernier élément très important parce que
vous avez fait allusion tout à l'heure
c'est sur la question de la
sous-traitance
il y a par exemple des pays on peut
prendre la france aujourd'hui ou et les
nouvelles règles aujourd'hui font qu'il
ya une responsabilisation du donneur
d'ordres par rapport à l'ensemble des
sous-traitants ce qui se passe a fait
rire à la moyenne exactement ça fait
râler les grandes entreprises les isa
c'est trop compliqué et c est bien
écouter peut-être qu'il peut y avoir des
effets un petit peu négatif mais on voit
l'effet très largement positif que
pourrait avoir cette mesure je crois
qu'il faudrait y aller mais ça attention
ça n'est pas la question de la
législation européenne en tant que telle
alors justement les discussions vont bon
train depuis des mois pour imaginer le
prochain texte de cette directive est à
des lieues avec lucile devillers et
aurélie la face
être européen
cela veut aussi dire bénéficier de
règles du jeu équitables mise
cela signifie que les travailleurs car
devrait avoir le même salaire pour le
même travail dans le même pays c'était
en septembre dernier jean claude juncker
président de la commission européenne
prévient ses homologues devant les
députés européens
signant la possible fin du dumping
social en europe
il faut dire qu une pression sans
précédent s'exerce sur la commission
européenne et sa commissaire belge
marianne thyssen pour une réforme par le
haut de la directive de 1996 sur le
travail des tâches et abus manque de
contrôle concurrence déloyale les
attaques sont légion jusqu'à la menace
de manuel valls de ne plus appliquer le
texte si celui ci n'était pas réformée
le gouvernement français cherche
aujourd'hui à convaincre et beaucoup de
pays sont d'accord avec lui qu'il faut
changer qu'il doit y avoir une égalité
de traitement par le haut pour lutter
contre le dumping social qu'on doit
payer des cotisations sociales les plus
élevées
le nombre de travailleurs détachés
déclarés en france n'a jamais été aussi
élevé près de 300000 personnes 3300 % de
hausse depuis 2004 le front d'une
réforme par le haut et soutenue par
plusieurs pays l'allemagne la belgique
l'italie les pays bas et le luxembourg
l'espagne et les pays scandinaves mais
l'opposition est forte dans les pays de
l'est
onze pays dont la pologne principal pays
de départ des travailleurs détachés la
roumanie ou encore la hongrie ont
présenté un carton jaune à la commission
européenne
l'obligeant à revoir sa copie en visite
officielle à varsovie
myriam el khomri ministre du travail a
donc tenté de convaincre son homologue
polonaise
sans succès le texte doit pour être
validés être adoptée à la majorité
qualifiée une partie est loin d'être
gagnée
alors elisabeth morin-chartier question
volontairement provocatrice
vous croyez vous allez réussir à obtenir
un texte à la hauteur de l'enjeu août et
j'en ai la ferme volonté et le fait que
nous soyons co-rapporteur ma collègue
socialiste
agnès jongerius et moi même donc les
deux grands groupes du parlement
européen travaille ensemble pour
améliorer ce texte est déjà un très bon
signal parce que ça signifie que pour
faire ce texte il faut qu'on change
complètement et qu'on réforme
nos méthodes de travail habituellement
vous savez c'est une affaire que l'on
règle politiquement entre les différents
groupes politiques tués sur tel mais là
on voit mal qui va là on est le surnom
voilà on est plus sur des clivages
politiques on est sur un tricot entre
des positions politiques et des
positions nationales et nous avons
besoin de tout le monde au niveau du
parlement européen pour pouvoir avoir
une majorité importante au parlement de
telle sorte deux ans après et nous
puissions peser vis-à-vis du conseil de
conseils dont vous avez vu qu'au niveau
du conseil d'affaires n'est pas gagné
alors justement nicolas grau pourquoi ce
carton jaune de la part de ces onze pays
de l'est est ce qu'ils peuvent vraiment
pesé est-ce que ça bloque est ce que ces
blocs en vision intérêt c'est de pousser
ces deux applications d'intérêt
économique et à la limite on sera leur
place et ce qui effectivement du coup
ils disent on sera plus compétitif
c'est un c'est un ratio de rapports dans
les ressources du pays il faut voir que
par exemple pour un pays comme la
pologne selon quand comment vous prenez
les études etc
mais je dirais que l'apport des ouvriers
expatriés quelles que soient les statuts
cesser la troisième ressource à peu près
de la pologne ou la quatrième tout
dépend comment c'est ça passe la main
c'est d'abord c'est un apport donc je
dis pas que sans ça ils s'en sortent pas
mais je dirais que donc c'est un vecteur
d'exportation on va dire donc ils ne
veulent pas s'en priver
et le carton jaune est ce qu'il est
bloquant pour la commission européenne
est ce que marianne thyssen va devoir
vraiment revoir son texte bien passé
pour moi la question est plus là et
souvent ce qu'il ya c'est qu'il ya des
positions très fermes avant et qu en
général si on tient faire
maman le bout et qu'on la firme
finalement parce que si vous regardez
sur le papier la majorité qualifiée
enfin vous allez me répondre mais n'est
pas loin donc ces pays sont peut-être
nombreux ils pèsent pas grand chose
d'accord il ne pèse pas grand chose donc
ils n'ont pas la majorité
j'irai 2 fait suffisant deng d'une part
comme vous avez dit c'est un carton
jaune donc juste il lève le carton puis
c'est tout en gros et on passe si la
commission 21 sa position passe et si le
parlement trouve sa majorité qualifiée
ils seront en minorité mais la fa l'air
et de textes la sphère est dépassé la
sphère du carton jaune permettez moi de
le préciser
la commission a maintenu sa proposition
le carton jaune était à la commission
elle maintient et nous parlement nous
avons commencé notre travail et nous
poursuivons notre travail
donc la sphère du carton jaune elle vous
pouvez la prendre comme un indicateur
comme un indice comme un état d'esprit
de ces pays qui ont levé le carton jaune
mais vous ne pouvez plus dire
aujourd'hui que le carton jaune et
bloquant guillaume balas manuel valls
qui dit que si le texte n'est pas à la
hauteur il ne l'a pris planning ne
l'appliquera plus est ce que c'est
possible je pense quatre choses à éviter
dans cette affaire la première chose
c'est de penser que les pays de l'est ce
sont un bloc
pourquoi parce que on a vu avec
elisabeth morin-chartier aujourd'hui
même des syndicalistes polonais le plus
grand syndicat que tout le monde connaît
en pologne qui s'appelle solidarnosc qu
et qui est pour la révision de la
directive c'est le cas en république
tchèque
c'est le plat en slovaquie ah oui vous
savez ça voilà les travailleurs les
salariés aujourd'hui demandent la
révision de la directive qui sont
nomades dans des boulots qui sont des
bouleaux d'esclavagé moderne
donc si vous voulez attention il ya les
gouvernements via la société dans ces
pays et cette société elle aspire aussi
au bien-être
la deuxième chose à éviter c'est qu'il
ne faut pas non plus mépriser les pays
de l'est dans le sens que je pense qu'on
les a aussi enfermé dans cette économie
low cost là ça demande des révisions qui
sont pas simplement de l'ordre social
mais aussi que c'est quoi la politique
économique de l'union européenne et de
justice sur le territoire il y aurait à
mon avis beaucoup de choses à dire et je
pense qu'il ya une grande renégociation
à faire avec le pays de l'est
aujourd'hui sur ce sujet et la troisième
chose qui vous poser la question sur
notamment ce qu'a dit manuel valls c'est
que je crois qu'il faut faire extraits
mon attention à ce qu'on raconte sur ces
sujets là il est possible que si tout
échoue et je pense pas que ça sera le
cas mais que si tout échoue un jour
notre pays doivent prendre ses
responsabilités mais attention parce que
si jamais nous en étions là ça serait la
fin de l'aventuré européenne
avec toutes ses conséquences possibles
donc notre urgence aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas de menacer l est de convaincre
et notamment de convaincre les autres
pays que nous pouvons bouger dans cette
affaire il est parfois pas inutile de
mettre une petite épée de damoclès sur
les têtes mais si on en met trop on
braque et on avance plus la menace elle
est bidon l es deux maisons que voilà
parce qu'il veut pas le dire mais moi je
vais vous le dire elle est totalement
bidon valls ou fait un numéro je suis
fort et vous allez voir ce que je vais
faire mais il va s'écraser d'abaisser
son slip
parce que non parce que la vraie raison
c'est que les français
combien de français sans travailleurs
détachés bénéficient de cette directive
troisième pays exportateur il est
troisième pays à bénéficier de cette
directive dont dans ce que l'on perd
d'un côté le problème c'est que ceux qui
perdent ce n'est pas ce qu'ils gagnent
mais globalement la france est plus
dépendante dans cette directive
elle exporte ses travailleurs qui
viennent entre guillemets faire du
dumping dans d'autres pays peut-être
mais vous savez bien qu'il y avait un
petit jeu mal à ce moment là quand
manuel valls a dit ça parce que je vous
rappelle une chose c'est que si cette
directive est réouverte c'est parce que
françois hollande en tant que président
de la république a lui même insisté
auprès de ses collègues au conseil pour
réouvrir cette directive dont il y avait
un petit jeu franco français entre le
président de la république et son
premier bébé alors réalisable et vous
savez au niveau européen on peut pas
jouer à ça c'est pas les petits jeux
nationaux qui nous feront avancer
alors justement qu'est ce que vous
proposez dans ce rapport que ce qui pour
vous est important ce qui sera encore
important d'obtenir en fait sur cette
future directive
qu'est ce qui est important d'obtenir
d'abord que l'on ce que l'on soit bien
d'accord
tous ensemble sur la durée du
détachement donc 24 au lieu de 36 24
mois le ca c non non mais là ce que
c'est la proposition 24 mois c'est la
proposition de la commission et donc de
la commissaire marianne thyssen
et il faut voir s'il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
on est sur quoi sont deux mois le
détachement non mais vous aurez pas on
est en pleine négociation alors vous
savez c'est pas ici que je vais mettre
les menottes pour ne pas pouvoir
négocier
donc on va avoir sur la durée à travers
les rebelles assurent salaire égal enfin
pas travailler gabriela cieux c'est
justement c'est très important a eu un
texte de la commission aujourd'hui et
pas très clair l'idée c'était de dire en
gros il faut que la rémunération est pas
simplement le salaire des travailleurs
détachés soit égale à la rémunération
des travailleurs locaux
donc les vidéos et une treizième mois et
sert à tout à faire des conventions
collectives ce que en france
les conventions collectives sont
généralement d'application universelle
il ya des pays cv les conventions
collectives sont des publications
sectorielles bon donc tout ça est
compliqué mais il faut que ce soit plus
clair parce que le texte de la
commission aujourd'hui il énonce des
principes et on voit pas bien où il veut
aller
et il faut bien distinguer ce qui est de
l'ordre du salaire et de ce qui est de
l'ordre de la rémunération et de qu'est
ce qu'on met entre les deux tout ça doit
être vraiment quelque chose d'indiquer
deuxième élément qui je crois est
extrêmement important c'est lutter
contre les sociétés boîtes aux lettres
c'est pas dans le texte aujourd'hui on
verra si on peut l'améliorer ou pas mais
ça serait nécessaire c'est mettre des
conditions sûres qui peut détacher des
travailleurs est ce que une réalité est
ce qu'une entreprise qui n'a pas 25 %
par exemple de son activité dans un pays
peut vraiment détaché des travailleurs
nicolas grau vous aurez le dernier mot
est ce que comme comme on vient de le
voir il ya une possibilité de sortir un
petit peu par le haut et de faire en
sorte comme le disait le monsieur là le
routier dans le premier reportage de
créer une europe sociale et d'augmenter
les salaires des pays de l'est
je suis pas sûr que la directive des
travailleurs même amélioré permettra
d'augmenter les salaires des pilotes et
c'est la situation économique dans les
piles c'est d'ailleurs si vous regardez
la pologne le salaire minimum a
énormément augmenté dans ces pays c'est
pour ça que petit à petit ils ont un
vrai problème d'ailleurs de de
travailleurs qualifiés en pologne
c'est pas la question d'aujourd'hui moi
je pense que il ya un point qui est
fondamental sur lequel on les européens
devraient réfléchir c'est que pour moi
ce système de façon plus générale de
directives ou dix ans après on se dit
parce que après il faudra que les han
il faudra encore trois ans pour qu'elle
soit appliquée plus trois ans pour dire
qu'elle ait des records depuis plus de
trois ans et ce sera déjà obsolète elle
sera déjà obsolète il faut qu'on invente
un système comme il ya dans certains
pays en france par exemple comme la
circulaire d'application on puisse très
vite corriger ou interpréter notion qui
dans la vie active paraît flou parce
qu'on l'a laissé sciemment flou et ou
parce que de nouveaux phénomènes sont à
sont apparus sans attendre dix ans de
plus pour la mettre en oeuvre et je
pense que c'est à ce niveau là d'une
espèce de délégations qu'on pourrait
faire à automatiquement à un nouveau
corps n'ait tout simplement à la
commission européenne pour par voie
d'interprétation en attendant la
prochaine directive dire il faut
entendre par travail est rattachée ou
par société intérimaire tel et de
manière à sortir un petit peu duflot
avoir une organisation encore ben je
vais vous dire une chose y un point qui
est bien c'est qu'on a des directives
d'application qui nous permettent
justement de faire ces évolutions
par contre sur vous dire une chose c'est
que le parlement est en codécision avec
le conseil et je pense que sur ce point
là je le pouvoir politique doit
continuer à faire évoluer les textes
européens
eh bien écoutez merci à tous de nous
avoir expliqué ce dossier un petit peu
difficile parce que c'est vrai que de
prime abord c'est un petit peu abscons
le travail des tâches et donc merci a
vous rendez vous la semaine prochaine
et si même avec ahmed tazir bonne
semaine à tous ciao